-I'm so happy to have you on.
-I'm so happy to be here.
I hope I don't have to do
a plank or anything.
-No, no, no.
Not everyone has to do --
-I saw a lot of
physical exercise on this stage.
-This is all just talking
and getting to know each other.
-Great. I love talking.
-I -- Congrats on everything.
-Thank you.
-What a year for you.
I want to talk --
Well, can we just talk about
the single cover?
Is this --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The song is giant,
but what is the cover here?
Is this a real --
-Yeah, it's my
actual middle finger.
-That's your --
-But -- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That -- You should've seen
that with skin on.
It was -- Mnh-mnh.
-But what happened to you?
-I wish I had this
exciting story of, like,
I was, like,
fighting a bear or something.
-Yeah.
-No.
I -- Literally,
I had to take my dog out,
and it was raining outside.
My dog didn't want to
go outside,
so she was, like,
under my mom's bed.
And so then I rang
the front-door bell,
and then she,
like, started sprinting
and she started barking.
And then she saw it was me,
so she went to run
under the bed.
And so I literally started
sprinting after her.
I went to, like,
reach and grab her harness.
I tripped and
fell at the same time
and I went to catch myself.
I literally
remember looking down
and I caught myself, like --
Like, I don't want to
flip you off.
-No, no. I know.
-But, like,
if you look, she's still --
-Yes, you're double flipping
me off right now.
-Yeah, you're welcome.
I thought you
needed the comparison, you know?
-But it turned out it ended up
like this, but with skin on it.
-With skin on it.
It was disgusting.
It was terrible.
-So, what happened then?
You went to the hospital?
-So, I went to the hospital.
My poor mother just had
a knee replacement, right?
Two weeks post-op.
It's just the two of us.
She's trying to drive me.
She has a really bad,
like, gag reflex
if she sees anything
that grosses her out.
Like, she'll -- And, so, she was
sitting there dry-heaving,
and I'm sitting here
and I'm like, "It's my hand!
This is my hand!
You don't get to throw up
on my hand!"
-"Stop talking! Ugh!"
-And I'm sitting here like,
"I don't know what's going on!
Look away!"
-Tell me about "abcdefu."
I mean, it exploded --
Was it TikTok?
Was that where --
-Yeah, I mean, I would
definitely, like --
I could definitely take it back
and pinpoint it, I mean,
as much as I can.
All of this is so, like -- The
fact that I'm here, I'm like --
I've pretended that this --
I've been sitting on this couch
for like years in my house,
and now I'm here.
Like, that's so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
-You're here. You did it.
-And it's thanks to this, like,
app on my phone.
Like, I mean, I posted the song.
Like, I had it out.
And, I mean,
it was out for a couple months,
and there's
some videos made to it,
but, like, not really a lot.
And I started seeing --
I really started seeing, like,
sign language
being connected to the song.
Like, anytime
I heard anything --
Like, the first time I saw
anything being a trend
of anything, it was, like,
putting sign language to "abc."
And I also -- I thought it was
really exciting just --
or really cool to have, like,
people to want to learn
sign language
because of maybe my song
to, like --
That was
really interesting to me,
And even just, like,
the hard-of-hearing, deaf side
of TikTok really started
and, like,
gave people the ability
to sing that song.
And I'm literally so grateful
for that side of TikTok.
Like, it literally
started everything.
-That's amazing to hear,
'cause, usually,
you hear the other side of
TikTok and social media.
When you hear the good stuff,
it's like no one talks about it.
So that's awesome.
I remember hearing it for
the first time on the radio,
and I go,
"Oh, this is a massive song."
And then I was
asking you about it,
and you actually have
a video of the first time
you heard your song
on the radio.
-I do. I do.
-And if this doesn't give
you goose bumps --
Just check this out.
This is real. Check out Gayle.
-"abcdefu."
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God!
-♪ Forget you and your mom ♪
♪ And your sister and your job ♪
[ Screams ]
-It's that move.
It's that move like,
"Is this real?"
"You're seeing it, too.
You're hearing it, too.
It is real, right?"
-Oh, my God. So much screaming.
-What can we expect next?
Now, like, we want more.
But we do.
Let's enjoy this moment
while we have it.
-Yes, I have a song
coming out this month, actually.
-This month.
-This month. January.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gayle, it's a pleasure
to meet you.
-Happy to meet you, yes.
-Man, oh, man, you're talented.
Congrats on everything.
Gayle, everybody.
She is performing her song,
"abcdefu," when we come back.